si tuvieras que clasificar te frente a
otros en función de un rasgo específico
que diría eso sobre cómo los ves y cómo
te ven ellos a ti para averiguarlo
reunimos a seis personas les vendamos
los ojos y les pedimos que se
clasificaron entre sí según su peso
percibido luego los reorganizamos en
función de su peso real esto es la
clasificación
soy golosa pero igual me encantan las
verduras y las frutas
[Música]
[Risas]
yo soy vegetariano pero también soy muy
goloso yo también soy parte de los
golosos
supongo quiero decir yo también soy
goloso así lo estamos haciendo supongo
solo haciendo algunos lleva una dieta
estricta estaba en la dieta cetogénica
fue difícil porque te limitas en
carbohidratos pero una vez que vi los
números en la escala pensé está bien
está genial si lo hice durante dos años
y ya está dos años es mucho tiempo para
hacerte mucho tiempo como dije
intenté ser vegetariana durante dos años
pero soy anímica sí a veces me mareo un
poco creo que cualquier tipo de dieta
restrictiva yo tuve un problema de
transtorno alimenticio así que pasé debe
ganar a pasarme en plantas básicamente
para que sea menos o no sé menos tóxico
pero sé que la gente puede hacerlo sin
que sea un problema podría estar
generalizando aquí pero especialmente en
eeuu creo que sin duda hay un problema
adicción a la comida y ciertamente lo he
sentido en mi vida me he excedido mucho
creciendo azúcares diferentes en el lado
de mi papá él siempre cocinaba y luego
teníamos que comer más vegetales iba al
lado de mi mamá y ella trabajaba todo el
día así que no cocinaba y por lo general
termina va comprando mcdonald's o algo
pero no la más conveniente sí creo que
la comida cuando eres más joven se puede
ver en gran medida como un mecanismo de
supervivencia si eres alguien que está
experimentando algún tipo de trauma o
simplemente sufriendo de acoso o cosas
así es algo muy fácil en lo cual
encontrar placer exacto es súper
reconfortante también gratificante si
tuviera un día de trabajo o algo así
sería como me merezco un estado
no es la parte difícil verdad lo usas
para recompensar castigar está en todas
partes y siento que desde que me hice
vegetariano definitivamente mi acceso a
ciertos alimentos chatarra ha sido
limitado creo que una gran razón por la
que me hice vegetariano fue para ayudar
a controlar mi novio es vegano pero yo
nunca podría hacerlo y luego él quiere
que yo le cociné y yo sé cuál es su
relación con el ejercicio lo hacen de
cierta manera o lo hacen porque lo
disfrutan por ser anémica
a veces ya me siento muy mareada y sé
que si hago ejercicio me sentiré como
una basura el resto del día pero sí
quiero abdominales saben no tengo el
tipo de disciplina que mucha gente tiene
para hacer ejercicio sin embargo si lo
ves como una disciplina siento que tal
vez lo veas como una forma de no sé es
mejor una actividad divertida en lugar
de lucir abdominales creo que eso es
perfecto porque durante años he estado
yendo al gimnasio y me obligó a hacerlo
y lo he odiado por completo pero
últimamente yo diría que desde
septiembre del año pasado estoy en el
gimnasio a los 7 días de la semana de
tres son cinco horas diarias a mí me
gusta el levantamiento de pesas el tarde
o nunca ha sido me fue rich cada cuánto
vas al gimnasio ahora
yo diría dos o tres días solo porque mi
motivación no ha estado a la par dirías
que también estaba representando eso en
tu comida porque voy mucho al gimnasio
pero vuelvo a casa y como pasta no
entiendo si entendiendo muy bien
nadadora durante unos o diez años pero
luego conseguir trabajo y no me ejercité
por dos años luego me mi tiempo al dance
y estado haciéndolo durante mucho tiempo
así que sigo ejercitándome como cartero
diría que me muevo casi todo el día por
lo general voy al gimnasio y allí estoy
unas cinco o seis veces por semana y
toda mi vida siempre he practicado
deportes así que siempre he sido muy
activa
basado en el hecho de que creo que
podría ser más alto que sabrina creo que
debería moverse a mi derecha
bien no creo que deba ser el más ligero
eso es lo que dijo
yo
creo que fue leída sí creo que debería
asegurar que tienes que estar ti porque
crees que debería estar allí porque en
realidad está siendo bordet haría
también quiero pasarme en que suena
pequeña no en el mal sentido tú sientes
o frío si muy seguido y entonces mente
porque no tienes carne amar a carlos y
al comenzar
sabía que seguramente terminaría en el
extremo izquierdo
creo que ella y steve deberían cambiarse
adiós steve adiós sabrina ha sido bueno
estar a tu lado adiós
eres vegetal y la cambiamos entonces
muy bien ahora estoy al lado de sobrinas
y esperen quien está hacia mi derecha
riis
y creo que deberíamos que estoy de
acuerdo
contigo si
quieres estar
al final
basado en que hace ejercicios todos
estaban rich dijo que va al gimnasio dos
o tres veces por semana si entonces se
verían más activos la pasta y voy
ahora
creo que vamos bien
más liviano obvio me parece que todos
suenan como de dos metros de altura
espera dónde crees que debemos estar sí
sabrina no es que rubén y tú deberías o
iba a decir yo y rubén hagamos nos
parecemos estoy de acuerdo con el cambio
entre sabrina y está bien hagámoslo
somos literalmente la misma
y alguien siente que está en el lugar
equivocado ahora yo aún si creo que al
menos steve y yo deberíamos cambiar al
menos sentí que estaba equivocada porque
de nuevo sólo con escuchar su voz y
escuchar sus antecedentes nunca lo
hubiera considerado más grande entonces
cuando se estaba moviendo sentí que
podría pero no quiero decir que no fuese
honesta que estaba menos presión puedo
decir el programa que estoy haciendo en
sí está bien estoy en un programa para
bajar de peso estoy en un programa
bariátrico en el que estoy en lista de
espera para hacerme una bcg que es
cuando corta en el 80% de tu estómago
para permitirte perder peso estoy en ese
programa por lo que creo que debería
cambiar puedo decir algo muy rápido
claro
sabrina yo hice ese programa
y entonces
mi
amigo quería quitarme la máscara y
abrazarla eso fue duro escuchas a
alguien pasar por eso y sabes lo que se
requiere para admitir que lo necesitas y
sabes lo que se necesita para decir que
lo haces por tu salud al [ __ ] lo demás
es por mi salud quiero seguir adelante
si cuando escuché eso mi corazón dio
vueltas fue raro felicidades por esa
decisión por cierto solo debo decir que
es un gran realmente te operé señora
desde los dije si ella está convencida
sobre cambiar de posición creo que se
conoce mejor que nosotros a ella
obviamente si quieres hacerlo sólo hazlo
estoy segura sabrina un poco lee sí
quién está conforme con el orden actual
de la línea
también estoy de acuerdo
se reorganizarán en función de su peso
real 1 2 3
oh dios mío
nadie se ve como lo imaginaba
yo estaba como tratando de solo dije no
creo que nos hayamos equivocado en el
lugar número 6 tenemos a leila con 44
kilos
en el lugar número 5 tenemos a carmen
con 62 kilos y medio en el lugar número
4 tenemos a rubén con 79 kilos en el
lugar número 3 tenemos a steven con 100
kilos en el lugar número 2 tenemos a
sabrina con 140 kilos y en el lugar
número 1 tenemos a richard con 143 kilos
bueno lo puedo decir ahora en los
últimos cuatro años he perdido 68 kilos
pesar 200 kilos me siento mucho mejor
conmigo mismo y me concentro mucho más
la mía es una gran parte de mi vida
ahora porque quiero tener hijos tienes
que estar saludable para hacerlo en
general sobre cómo me veo fui a méxico e
incluso mis amigas me preguntaban por
qué no publicas ninguna foto y yo les
dije a mí acá porque estoy fea no me
gustó como salía en ninguna de las fotos
así que al llegar llamé al médico y le
dije puedo unirme al programa no eres
fea siento decirte
que no sé por qué no querrías publicar
sí eres hermosa no estoy diciendo que
porque estás tratando de perder peso eso
signifique que no te gustan tus fotos
pienso que eres hermosa a pesar de
gredos jazz puedes hacer lo que quieras
con tu cuerpo sabes bueno si yo solía
pesar 204 kilos
he sido grande toda mi vida lo de la
adicción a la comida fue lo que me
atrapó y hablé sobre eso fue muy real
estoy sobrio desde hace 3 años y me hice
la cirugía bariátrica hace 2 años y
medio dejar la comida fue más difícil
que dejar el alcohol y eso me sacudió es
tan difícil como decir que me rompí la
pierna necesito que me la arreglen
quirúrgicamente estaba en un punto en el
que mi mente y mi cuerpo estaban añado
que necesitaba que los arreglará y la
idea errónea que odio es que es la
salida fácil pero no ven el duro proceso
mental y lo que estoy pasando ahora para
solucionar los problemas de identidad en
los que estaba trabajando y todo eso
todavía hay mucho de mí quebrantado por
eso solo quiero decirte que siento que
te estabas menospreciando y tú también
ahora que estoy aquí me doy cuenta de
que no estuve diablos me doy cuenta de
que no estuve tan mal cuando estuve allí
entonces no creo que ustedes están
pasándola mal ahora verdad esta es la
parte hermosa y creo que en la visión de
la positividad
corporal es muy enferma porque cuando
estaba tratando de perder peso todos
aquí en los ángeles decían no eres
hermoso no lo hagas y yo pensaba no
estoy enferma me estaba muriendo no se
trataba de mi belleza siendo la de menos
peso aquí siendo anémica en el límite de
la prediabetes tengo muchos problemas
solo por mi estilo de vida pero no
necesariamente tengo ese peso yo solo
porque hacía mucho ejercicio muchos
deportes fui muy delgada y cuando para
la gente solo asumió que tenía anorexia
y todo ese tipo de cosas pero yo estaba
bien comía bien y luego cuando dejaron
de ser comentarios pensé que básicamente
había explotado y luego desarrollé
dismorfia corporal y estaba teniendo
transtornos alimenticios y cuando perdí
peso haciendo eso la gente me felicitaba
y allí es una comparan el tamaño con la
salud pero yo estaba perdiendo cabello y
no estaba saludable pero como de delgada
decían oh está sana definitivamente es
importante que se encuentren a sí mismos
porque como un tipo grande atribuí mi
identidad a mi tamaño y ahora estoy
atrapado en terapia tratando de
descubrir quién soy porque siempre fui
el gran estímulo a mi vida ha sido el
gran rif y tengo dismorfia corporal
todavía veo al tipo que pesaba 204 kilos
en el espejo la gente piensa que cuando
pierdes peso la batalla termina pero
también hay un problema mental que se
supone que debes abordar si estás
luchando con tu peso ya sea que quieras
aumentarlo o reducirlo comprende que hay
un aspecto mental que también debes
abordar y al final del día amate a ti
mismo se saludable pero hay más que solo
lo físico
i
[Música]